For this exercise, we're going to short
row shape a single side of a neckline.
This would be as if you were
knitting the front of a cardigan.
For the demo, I've added a simple stockinette band, but the focus is following
the pattern and the
shaping of the neckline.
Using short rows. Here is my pattern.
I'll start by casting on 28
stitches and knit for 24 rows.
I'm using a manual wrap method
for the short rows, so I'll be putting
needles into hold opposite the carriage.
My first instruction is
to bind off 6 stitches.
Instead of binding off,
I'm going to hold these 6 needles.
With my carriage and hold,
I'll knit across, wrap, and knit back.
Remember, the wrap prevents holes.
The next instruction is to bind
off or hold three stitches.
Knit, wrap, knit,
bind off two stitches,knit, wrap, knit.
And then we'll bind off one stitch
every other row five times.
Don't forget to wrap.
Remember, short row shaping
takes place on every other row.
So if your knitting pattern has you
knitting three rows or five rows or some
other combination, you'll need to adjust
your decreases for every other row.
With the shaping done,
before going any further,
I'm confirming that I have 12 stitches
in work and these will
be my shoulder stitches.
Keeping those shaping stitches in hold,
I'll finish knitting the rest
of the neck opening.
Notice that I'm adding weight
so the stitches knit properly.
Then I'll bind off.
This image isn't an exact replica
of my pattern, but the red dots represent
the stitches in hold and the green dots
represent the stitches
we are about to pick up.
Picking up stitches to rows, so
the pickup isn't one-to-one.
Plan on three stitches to four rows,
or maybe two stitches to three rows,
depending on your gauge.
Knit across all the stitches.
I used a contrasting color yarn.
And you have some options here.
You could knit the row with your garment
yarn and simply bind off the edge.
Or you could scrap off,
leaving live stitches.
Once you've knit and joined the back piece
of your sweater, you could then pick up
the bound off or scrapped off neck edges
and finish them with any method you like.